over the decade bank fraud are
increasing day by day these fraud can be
detected and reduced with the help of
supervised machine learning technique
throttle and transition show a specific
pattern and with the help of supervised
machine learning algorithms these
patterns can be separated from the
genuine ones these supervised machine
learning algorithms can identify
fraudulent activity a lot quicker and
with more exactness than traditional
based systems
hello everyone my name is maya from
simplyla in this video we will learn
what is supervised machine learning
we will look at how supervised machine
learning works we will also see some
advantages and disadvantages of
supervised machine learning we will
continue this session by understanding
supervised machine learning types
followed by supervised machine learning
algorithm
further we will have a quick look at
some real world application of
supervised machine learning
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and don't forget to press the bell icon
so you will never miss any update from
simply learn
but before we talk about supervised
machine learning let's quickly
understand what machine learning is
machine learning is the art of making
computers learn and act like humans by
fitting data and which focuses on
utilization of information and imitating
the way that people learn step by step
working on its accuracy
machine learning is playing a major role
in our day-to-day life
machine learning is used in trends and
pattern identification automation
weather forecasting and many more
machine learning is classified into
supervised machine learning unsupervised
machine learning reinforcement learning
semi supervised learning
let's understand supervised machine
learning in detail
wise machine learning machines are
trained using label data
also known as training data to predict
the results
here label data refers to a group of
data that have been tagged with one or
more names and data is already known to
the machine in the real world supervised
machine learning can be used for image
and object recognition predictive
analytics customer sentiment analysis
spam detection and many more
after understanding what supervised
machine learning is let's move forward
and see how supervised machine learning
works
suppose we have a data set that includes
dogs and cats
now the first step is that we need to
train the model for each dogs and cats
as per the factors like similarity
pattern shapes and contrast
now after training we test our model
using new data set which is unknown to
the model and the task of the model is
to identify the new input data
the machine is already trained on all
types of similarity patterns shapes and
contrast
when it finds new data it classifies it
on the basis of similarity patterns
shapes and contrasts and predict the
output
as of now we are well aware of how
supervised machine learning works let's
have a walkthrough of the advantages and
disadvantages of supervised machine
learning
before diving deep into any technology
it is very important to understand its
advantages and disadvantages here are
some advantages of supervised machine
learning first one is real world
computation problems help you to solve
various types of real world computation
problems like spam detection image and
object recognition and many more the
second one is optimization using past
experience supervised machine learning
can optimize performance criteria
the third one is prediction
in supervised machine learning models
can predict the output based on the past
experience as well
both one is reusable data we can reuse
the training data unless there is any
feature change
supervised machine learning has
advantages as well as disadvantages
let's have a look at some disadvantages
now
computation time is also known as
running time is very vast for the
supervised machine learning
supervisor machine learning models
always need updates
pre-processing of data a big challenge
for predicting the output anyone can
overlap supervised machine learning
easily it occurs when a statical model
is exactly against its training data
now that we have an understanding of
advantage and disadvantages let's move
forward and discuss different types of
supervised machine learning
supervised machine learning can be
further classified into two problems
which are classification regression
let's see them one by one in detail
classification is a process of in which
new observations are recognized and
separated in such a way that they can be
categorized
assuming you have a group of things for
example vegetables you can categorize
them based on their properties that they
have like you can arrange the potatoes
in class a tomatoes in class b capsicum
in class c
these are some popular classification
algorithms that come under supervised
machine learning first one is random
forest second is season trees third one
is logistic regression fourth one is
support vector machines
moving forward let's have a look on
regression
a regression algorithm is used to figure
out the connection between dependent and
independent variables dependent
variables are nothing but are variables
which we are trying to predict or
forecast
and independent variables means that
factors that influence the analysis it
is usually used to make projection for
example we have variable 1 as humidity
and variable 2 s temperature where
humidity will play the role of dependent
variable and in temperature will be the
independent variable humidity and
temperatures are correlated in such a
way that as temperature increases
humidity will decrease and vice versa
many organizations utilize regression
models to predict how stocks will act
from here on this is done by breaking
down the past information on a stock
cost and trends to recognize pattern
these are some popular regression
algorithms that comes under supervised
machine learning first one is linear
regression second one is regression
trees
third one is non-linear regression
fourth one is bayesian linear regression
after discussing the advantages and
disadvantages of supervised machine
learning and its types let's move
forward to see algorithms in supervised
machine learning
in computer programming terms an
algorithm is a set of well-defined
instruction to solve a particular
problem it takes a bunch of information
sources and delivers the ideal result
the first supervised machine learning
algorithm is linear regression
linear regression is utilized to
recognize the connection between
dependent variable and at least one
independent variable and is commonly
utilized to make forecasts about future
results companies frequently use linear
regression models to predict
future sales this can be useful for
things like planning and arranging
algorithms like amazon product to
product collaborative filtering are
utilized to predict what clients will
purchase later on given their past
purchase history
a regression tree is worked through a
cycle known as binary recursive
partitioning which is an additive
interaction that divides the information
into segments or branches and afterwards
keep splitting each data into smaller
groups as a technique climbs each branch
these trees are used for dependent
variables with continuous value for
example a regression tree named food
which divides into segments wedge and
non-width
further it keeps splitting into smaller
groups
non-linear regression is a type of
regression examination wherein
information is fed to model and
afterward communicate it as a numerical
function simple linear regression
relates two factors with a straight line
while non-linear regression relates the
two factors in a non-linear relationship
non-linear regression can be used to
predict population growth over time
or the relationship between gdp and the
time of a country
this algorithm is a way to deal with
linear regression in which the statical
examination is attempted inside the
settings of pcn inference linear
regression and patient regression can
generate the same prediction and with
the help of bayesian processing we can
retrieve the complete variety of
inferential solution instead of point
estimate
random forest is one of the most
adaptable supervised machine learning
algorithm utilized for both
classification and regression purposes
random forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous branches
including banking stock exchanging
mitigation it is utilized to predict the
things which assist these businesses
which running productively like client
activity patient history and safety
a decision tree is a very specific sort
of tree that empowers you to conclude
some kind of process used for dependent
variables with discrete values for
example we want to pick between
manufacturing product a on product b or
putting resources into disease at one
decision two or decision three decision
trees are an outstanding method for
managing these kinds of complex choices
logistics regression is calculated
logically and chosen when the dependent
variable is categorical meaning they
have double results for example logistic
reaction can be used to predict whether
a political nominee will win or lose a
political race or regardless of whether
a secondary school student will be
admitted up to a specific school a
support vector machine is a well-known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for the two information
classification and regression all things
considered it is regularly utilized for
grouping issues like we can involve in
different life care systems we can
involve in typically happy and sad look
arrangement
we can involve in filters if we make
specific loops it would add the
particular filter according to the
expression the scope of articulation
lies between happy and sad after
understanding supervised machine
learning algorithms let's move forward
and cover applications of supervised
machine learning choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
supervised machine learning models can
be used to build an advanced several
businesses application including the
following the first one is image and
object recognition supervised machine
learning models can be utilized to find
isolate and assort objects out of
recordings of pictures
making them valuable when applied to
different computer design strategies and
imaginary analysis the second one is
predictive analysis a broad use case
course provides machine learning models
is in making predictive analytics
systems to give profound experience into
different business data of interest this
permits to expect specific outcomes
because of a given result variable
assisting business leaders to justify
choices or turn to serve the association
the third one is customer sentiment
analysis utilizing supervised machine
learning models association can extract
and arrange significant pieces of data
from huge volumes of information
including context emotion and purpose
with very little human intervention
this can be incredibly valuable while
acquiring a superior understanding of
client collaboration and can be utilized
to further develop brand engagement
efforts the fourth one is spam detection
spam identification is another
application of supervised machine
learning model
utilizing classification calculation
companies can prepare data sets to
recognize patterns or anomalies and new
information to sort out spam and
non-spam related data
so as we have seen all the major aspects
of supervised machine learning we will
conclude this video
the objective of supervised machine
learning is to construct a machine
learning models that can get familiar
with the planning between data and the
results and can predict the output of
the following given data sources it is
the most straightforward sub-category of
machine learning and serves as an
introduction to machine learning to many
machine learning specialist
most generally utilized type of machine
learning has been demonstrated to be an
excellent tool in many fields we have
reached the end of this video i hope you
guys found this video informative and
helpful if you have any doubts or
feedback feel free to ask them in
comment section below we will happy to
help you if you like this video please
subscribe to our channel and don't
forget to hit the bell icon thank you
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here